olá eu sou médico neurologista formado
eu entrei na faculdade
atrás efe doutorado em genética
cinco anos atrás eu larguei um
consultório 11 uma carreira de
pesquisador que é uma carreira acadêmica
em genética para montar um laboratório
de genética junto com pessoas muito mais
inteligentes do que eu chamo de links
é nesses cinco anos eu tive uma
oportunidade incrível de ver um futuro
que como que o pt já tinha escrito é que
o futuro já está aqui ele só não tá e
comente distribuído é e eu vejo esse
futuro no dia a dia porque a gente cria
esse tipo de coisa a gente é exposto eu
sou exposto todos os dias há uma
tecnologia de inteligência artificial de
informática de genômica é que é incrível
e isso coloca um pouco a minha visão do
que vai ser o futuro do que vai ser a
prática médica
ele falou um pouquinho do que eu acho
que vai acontecer nos próximos 20 anos
em contraposição ao que aconteceu nos
últimos 80 anos a medicina evoluiu
drasticamente nos últimos 80 anos
a minha avó entrou na faculdade medicina
é médica tem 93 anos de idade entrou na
faculdade em 1944 é a medicina que ela
viu ao longo desses 70 anos neste caso é
mudou radicalmente e ela mudou por
algumas razões é muito específicas que
permearam da medicina que vários dos
palestrantes falaram sobre isso
a primeira coisa é são os medicamentos
ou o tratamento como como um todo
a gente ganhou um conhecimento sobre as
bases biológicas das doenças nos últimos
70 e 80 anos que nos permitirão tratar
os pacientes com uma eficácia com uma
eficiência muito maior então a gente
entende a gente consegue é entender qual
o que os pacientes têm e por toda a
gente consegue tratar esses pacientes de
uma maneira muito melhor tempo muito
longo e ainda andar mas a gente melhorou
mundo
pensar que em 1944 era quando o a
penicilina estava chegando no brasil né
então uma medicina que era feita antes
da penicilina e depois da penicilina só
medicinas muito diferentes
só pensar na não aqui na escola na
faculdade de medicina ali do outro lado
da cidade é que foi onde eu fiz
faculdade é ter uma cadeira de sífilis
tinha um especialista em si feliz que
deixou de ter razão de existir depois
que existiu a penicilina
a gente ainda aprende sobre simples ela
ainda existe é mas não precisa de um
especialista de um professor titular de
sífilis é da mesma maneira como durante
alguns anos se discutir por exemplo um
professor titular sobre de hiv e aids
a outra coisa que mudou muito a medicina
nesses últimos 80 anos foram os exames
de imagem é os exames de imagem desde a
década de 90 ressonância e tomografia
permitiram com que a gente enxergasse
algumas coisas nos pacientes nos
processos de doença que a gente antes
não conseguia enxergar isso revolucionou
algumas áreas da medicina muito mais do
que outras
é esse o neurologista eu aprendi ainda
um exame neurológico muito detalhado mas
já era muito diferente do que alguém que
fez residência em 1970 aprendeu é porque
a gente já tinha muito mais informação
ea gente tinha quase que o padrão ouro
você faz um exame físico mas você tem
alguma informação importante a mais para
saber qual é o processo de doença que
está acontecendo um paciente
a outra coisa que aconteceu é que é
difícil escrever próprios meios ou eu
supostamente em casa ainda no milan eu
sou do bem no limite é dos mais velhos
dos milênios mas o que aconteceu nessa
transição aqui a internet mudou o acesso
à informação é quando eu entrei na
faculdade um pouco antes a gente tinha
aqui na biblioteca cheio o carro é livre
revista esperar as revistas chegarem
aqui é na biblioteca pra gente ter as
informações
hoje em dia você tem acesso a um pdf do
ou ao life de de um congresso
enquanto ele está acontecendo então
acesso à informação acesso aos
pesquisadores isso como mais fácil e
isso foi democratizado não custa nada
ele custa o acesso à internet a medicina
então mudou muito mas se você olhar
prática médica o dia a dia do médico é
claro que ele tem mais ferramentas nós
temos mais ferramentas para tratar
diagnosticar os pacientes mas a prática
no dia a dia isso é uma foto daquele
capelas em 1938 por que eu tô falando 80
anos é medindo a pressão arterial do
paciente é medindo a temperatura do
paciente quando tem uma suspeita de
infecção fazendo um exame de sangue
essas coisas mudaram muito pouco né este
processo em que um médico senta com o
paciente conversa com o paciente
isso mudou muito pouco né é tem mais
informações têm mais conhecimento tem
mais ferramentas mas o dia a dia do
médico mudou pouco e é isso que nos
próximos 20 anos vai mudar radicalmente
então para os alunos de medicina para
quem fazendo medicina hoje isso é muito
importante porque quando vocês estiverem
no pico da carreira
a menina vai vai deixar você está atrás
se vocês olharem o histórico dos últimos
80 anos e tentaram traçar uma linha reta
é do que vai acontecer porque a gente
está acelerando muito o conhecimento ea
tecnologia e algumas coisas em
particular que eu vou falar aqui adiante
já na década de 50 gente falou de star
trek e star wars
eu gostava de estar fraca é r 2
mas nos estoques a gente tinha uma visão
é globalizada uma visão é de 11 que a
tecnologia podia levar pra gente vai
correr é que era um aparelhinho que o
doutor foca carregava e fazia o
diagnóstico em tempo real é adquirir
todas as informações eles não tinham
conhecimento médico mas adquire as
informações já dá o diagnóstico e já é
medicar vou dar o tratamento e e esse é
um sonho mas isso está se tornando
realidade ele vai se tornar realidade
nos próximos anos é é
o que mudou essa prática o que está
gerando quais são os fatores causadores
dessa mudança fundamental na prática
médica nos próximos 20 anos
coisas que aconteceram nos últimos 10 20
anos
tá primeiros dois fatores é a gente
pensa um é o celular
o acesso em qualquer momento a
informação é mais do que isso não é só o
acesso à informação mas hoje a gente tem
na nossa mão todo mundo tem não só
acesso à internet ou por mero naquela
hora mas a gente tem uma máquina
fotográfica a gente tem sensores
diversos
a gente tem é aplicativos que permitem a
gente fazer os cálculos que a gente
antes tinha que manter na nossa cabeça a
gente tem uma ferramenta de comunicação
constante que era que não existia há nem
dez anos veio dez anos atrás
além disso a gente não precisa ter todo
o poder computacional na nossa mão é a
amazon 2002 quando percebeu que eles
usavam muito mais os servidores deles
nas três semanas antes do natal porque
era ali que tinha o grosso do é da
demanda por computação né de servidores
deles
eles tinham os seus idade no resto do
ano então eles resolveram usar essa
ociosidade e vender esse tempo de
servidor e com isso começou em
processamento em nuvem é a nuvem que
hoje a gente fala o que quer não vem a
nuvem é acesso quase que infinito
a computação então hoje você pode ter
acesso a uma computação no celular e
você tem acesso a uma computação que
está à distância infinita simplesmente
você precisar o que você precisa fazer
com com isso você pode
a outra coisa que vai mudar é é que a
gente vai ter com compartilhamento
a gente tinha 200 milhões de
computadores no mundo hoje em 2 bilhões
de celulares e smartphones
quando você tem algo que acontece nessa
ordem de grandeza o custo dos aparelhos
o curso
dos componentes cai muito e com a queda
do custo dos componentes outras coisas
foram surgindo em volta que a gente num
mercedes no dia a dia mas o mesmo
processador que serve para um smartphone
serve para um drone serve para um carro
que dirige sozinho né então todas essas
coisas vão surgir em volta desse
ecossistema diz uma fonte que surgiu
nesses últimos dez anos
foi então que quer a gente fala claro um
paciente pode medir a glicemia é pra
dividir é é a glicemia dele em casa um
paciente diabético tipo 1 pode medir
várias vezes por dia hoje em dia a gente
tem até medidores contínuos que ficam é
colocado no subcutâneo do paciente
mas e quando a gente puder medir todas
as outras coisas que a gente mede em
laboratórios centrais como a mãe da linx
é é a distância isso não acontece da
noite para o dia mas ele está
acontecendo muito rápido e isso vai
permitir que a gente aquela aquele ciclo
longo que a gente precisava pedir exame
para o paciente ele ia para um
laboratório voltava isso vai vai passar
muito rápido
um exemplo desses eu não tenho nenhuma
participação nesta empresa tá é mas tem
essa esse ultrassom portátil ultrassom
antes custava 80 100 mil dólares é hoje
em dia esse é um dom que é custa 6 mil
dólares mais ou menos né então um médico
poderia carregar este ultrassom no seu
bolso
ao invés de ao escutar um paciente
tentar através apenas dos sons saber se
o paciente tem uma condensação pulmonar
ou uma miocardiopatia ele vai enxergar
essa informação e ele vai poder
comunicar essa informação com muito mais
dado para é um servidor central que vai
processar as informações de devolver
parte dessas informações processadas ele
vai ter a ferramenta no momento a gente
vai ter a ferramenta no momento que a
gente está vendo o paciente e não num
ciclo longo de sai marca uma consulta
volta a marcar o exame volta essa coisa
de um mês volta a gente vai fazer em
tempo real
o sequenciamento genético
isso é uma foto do caminho dele que tem
hoje a gente tem três seqüenciadores de
grande capacidade de produção
é eu não trouxe aqui não vim aqui para
falar da mãe dele especificamente eu só
trouxe um exemplo é é um sequenciador
que a gente tem que a gente comprou
quatro anos atrás
hoje isso é um seqüenciador chama no pó
ele faz metade do que o sequenciador que
comprou quatro anos atrás a já fazia vai
continuar essa miniaturização não é só
em genômica você vai continuar em todas
as áreas e imagem em genética em exames
laboratoriais na interpretação e mais no
tratamento robótica vai mudar temos
segunda coisa que aconteceu o segundo
grupo de fatores que vão mudar
um deles é o videogame é porque
videogame e por isso que eu gosto muito
dessa visão que a gente nunca sabe da
onde que vai vir a inovação é e inovação
veio em grande parte dos aficionados por
videogame e queriam capacidade de
processar são de vídeo cada vez maior e
essa capacidade de processamento de
vídeo que foi aumentando é ao longo dos
anos de um salto gigantesco também na
última década com os processadores de
vídeo as placas de vídeo
essas portas fazem cálculos muito
rapidamente uma capacidade muito grande
que se percebeu mais recentemente e aqui
a outra imagem é uma imagem sobre um
algoritmo de inteligência artificial é
isso é um tipo de diploma nem é é é que
os algoritmos de inteligência artificial
aqueles aqueles algoritmos que existiam
desde a década de 60 e 70 e que não
funcionavam direito
agora com a capacidade de processamento
através dos gp uns das placas de vídeo e
através da quantidade de dados que a
gente tem disponível a gente agora
juntando essas duas coisas fundando o
videogame juntando os dados que a gente
está coletando inteligência artificial
funciona ea gente vai ver um avanço a
gente está vendo todo dia novos avanços
em inteligência artificial que parecem
inacreditável isso é dois exemplos
rápidos
um é
a fala então interpretação de fala isso
é um gráfico da google mostrando como
nos últimos anos os modelos de
inteligência artificial os
classificadores de inteligência
artificial que interpretam fala já
chegaram no nível da interpretação
humana
aquela coisa a gente nunca vai entender
um paciente na verdade a gente vai
a gente já tá chegando no ponto em que
os classificadores fazem o inteligência
artificial faz outra um mesmo trabalho
de entender a fala que um ser humano
imagens a gente agora consegue
interpretar as imagens em vídeo
estáticas
a gente pode da mesma maneira que a
gente está interpretando então e que
agora a gente já está no nível humano já
está melhor do que o nível humano isso
vai continuar melhorando nos próximos
anos
a gente já tem algoritmos de
inteligência artificial que conseguem
fazer apologia então a primeira é o
primeiro comentário é de longo prazo é
que o reconhecimento de imagens não é um
modelo de carreira viável de longo prazo
então sim radiologia patologia
vai ser muito difícil ter um mercado pra
esse número de de radiologistas e
patologias que já existem
muito menos pra para os novos formandos
nos próximos 20 anos
a gente fala mas não teve sucesso você
nunca vai chegar no ponto em que vai
substituir a máquina não vai substituir
o ser humano né gente ouve isso muito em
áreas diferentes
a gente só raramente houve sobre o
médico é o exemplo do hemograma que na
década de 40 e 50 era feito com um
computador você pegava olhava no
microscópio uma pessoa olhava no
microscópio especialista e contava ali o
número de células que tinha por
milímetro cúbico e com isso você fazia
entregar um hemograma isso daí tem um
erro humano claro mas muito mais que
isso é muito caro você treinar um médico
para ficar contando as células num
formato x y z é e com os e teve muita
resistência quando os aparelhos
automáticos de contagem entraram no
mercado mas hoje em dia é a gente
prefere que os aparelhos alta
acho que isso é muito mais barato é e
permite que a gente faça hemogramas está
muito mais gente que fique acessível que
é parte do da minha missão pessoal da
missão pessoal ligado à missão da mãe
delas que é tornar acessível o
diagnóstico
então automatização robotização permite
que a gente se torne acessível e ninguém
hoje fala não esse programa foi
automatizado num eu não aceito esse
hemograma eu quero que um que um médico
olhe no nas sessões das recessões a
gente quer que nunca um especialista
olhe mas no geral não
então o que faz um médico na sua prática
ele obtém uma história clínica
eu já mostrei que pegar a informação de
fala dos pacientes a gente já está
chegando nesse ponto em que a gente vai
conseguir fazer
ele observa a gente consegue tirar de
gás essas imagens antes vai ter no bolso
um agente já tem no bolso uma câmera que
vai conseguir filmar o paciente ouvir o
paciente ele examina o paciente a gente
vai ter os aparelhos as ferramentas
necessárias na hora que o paciente
precisa a gente interpreta os exames o
médico interpreta exames um
eletrocardiograma que a gente já
consegue fazer já tem aplicativos de
iphone que fazem isso você já consegue
fazer patologia e na própria mãe dele
que a gente já tem algoritmos que a
gente mesmo desenvolveu para interpretar
a parte molecular seqüenciamento em alta
capacidade
é a gente conseguiu fazer isso na minha
ideia em genômica porque não tinha um
geneticista do mesmo jeito que tinha um
radiologista então já estava criando do
zero ninguém tinha expectativa de que um
médico fizesse isso o tempo todo né
então é a gente já começou com as
ferramentas é é nos auxiliando a fazer o
diagnóstico molecular o médico
diagnostica e um médico trata os robôs
vão andar um pouquinho mais mas o
cirurgião que acha que fazer aprendiz
economia é algo que o robô não consegue
fazer espera 15 anos
mais do que isso a questão da
criatividade
quando a google começou a fez o gol o
ritmo que chama alfa gol pra jogar o
joguinho que gol que é um jogo complexo
bem mais complexo do que
é chato 3 por exemplo e ganhou dos
principais jogadores mundiais não foi
isso que me chama atenção que me chama
atenção foi que os melhores jogadores
mundiais depois começaram a assistir o
afagou jogar pra aprender porque ele
usava técnicas criativas coisas
completamente novas que as pessoas que
estavam jogando isso há 30 anos nunca
tinha pensado em meu sapo é então a
gente vai começar a ver criatividade
arte sendo criada por inteligência
artificial
o ponto máximo que vai acontecer vai ser
o ponto é isso nos próximos anos que vai
fazer com que a gente perceba como
inteligência artificial evoluiu e vai
nos ajudar porque vai tornar isso daí é
disponível acessível para todo mundo que
precisa é quando a gente puder fazer o
diagnóstico em casa né não vai ser o
point of care vai ser em casa mesmo em
que a gente vai ter isso aqui é um
aparelho da amazon que chama alex a
vocês virem falar alexa
eu não tô me sentindo bem ela vai falar
o que você tem você vai falar eu tô
sentindo que está ardendo para urinar e
eu fui várias vezes urinar
ainda hoje alex vai falar medindo a
temperatura você não tem nenhum sinal de
febre ou de qualquer outra alteração
sistêmica
portanto é muito provável que você tenha
uma infecção urinária vai falar é que eu
faço o tratamento da infecção urinária é
uma norma fox assina duas vezes ao dia
durante três dias você deseja que a
gente já pensa isso da farmácia e
entregue na sua casa você diz sim você
vai tomar depois de três dias alex vai
virar pra você falar da vida você
melhorou paulo melhorei ótimo você
poupou uma visita a um médico só vai
acontecer mais rápido do que a gente
imagina o que vai acontecer rápido
porque nos últimos dez anos as coisas
que adotaram a tecnologia nos últimos 20
anos as coisas que adotaram a tecnologia
é
foram as áreas que teve decréscimo maior
de custo
as pessoas não têm acesso à medicina de
ponta que evoluiu nos últimos 80 anos
por uma questão de custo por uma questão
física de chegar até o lugar
todas essas coisas vão ser resolvidas
com isso que eu falei
até aqui o que vai acontecer é que isso
vai continuar crescendo por algum tempo
mas aí vai vai despencar do mesmo jeito
que um curso de uma televisão
antigamente era absurdo e hoje em dia é
acessível do mesmo jeito que o celular
você às vezes compra por 50 dólares
é numa banquinha é farmacêutica
então a gente deve ficar preocupado com
o nosso emprego médico né com a nossa
prática médica
de uma certa forma sim porque não vai
ter o emprego que existe hoje um médico
que existe hoje praticando não vai ter
essa oportunidade é daqui a 20 ou 30
anos tem muito menos espaço a mesma
coisa aconteceu com os contêiners em
1956 é um empresário americano inventou
os contêiners
é uma maneira muito mais eficiente de se
carregar os navios demorou dez anos para
isso se adotado mas em 66 quando isso
foi adotado mundialmente levou um ganho
de produtividade de 30 vezes centenas de
milhares de empregos que existiam antes
de carregadores de navios desapareceram
e centenas de milhares só em nova york
só no porto em nova york mas essas
pessoas não ficaram desempregadas o que
aconteceu foi que essas pessoas que
antes trabalhavam carregando os navios
agora elas tinham emprego diferente elas
trabalhavam na no transporte e todo o
resto que cresceu todo o comércio
internacional que cresceu com é a
facilidade ea queda no custo de
transporte e comércio internacional
então não é que você criou um milhão de
desempregados
migrou essas pessoas pra outras
oportunidades que apareceram
e se isso vai acontecer com o médico o
que vai acontecer e assim o que o médico
trás e aqui está a minha mensagem final
é uma coisa que a gente deve enfatizar
europeus um cara técnico enfatizei pouco
isso durante muitos anos e discutiu com
a esposa recentemente que na frente de
toda mulher inteligente tem um homem
querendo pegar é é crédito né
é a gente tava conversando sobre isso o
que o médico traz o que o dentista atrás
o que um profissional da saúde traz além
do conhecimento é é afeto empatia é e um
médico quando está tratando um paciente
do mesmo jeito de 80 anos atrás mesmo
que tinha pouco a fazer pelo paciente
a gente traz muito benefício para o
paciente
a gente tem que resgatar isso
para entender a nossa participação no
mundo que a gente não é o guardião do
conhecimento
mas a gente é é a melhor maneira de
levar o paciente para um uma qualidade
de vida melhor para um tratamento melhor
obrigado
[Aplausos]